will the pox get renamed so monkeys
won't feel ashamed
the w.h.o gets bitter about diseases
named after a critter
the world health organization is
changing the name of monkey pox because
names shouldn't reference places or
animals and it could be stigmatizing
true but what exactly is stigmatizing
the monkey part or the pox part
or the fact that you got infected from
anonymous depraved sex at outdoor
concerts
it's why i stopped eating bananas at
lollapalooza
but it's the name they got a problem
with virologists saying in the context
of the current global outbreak continued
reference to a nomenclature wow
uh scroll that back there of this virus
being african is not only inaccurate but
it's also discriminatory
and stigmatizing how could it be
discriminatory ed what about these guys
yeah pat has no idea what we're talking
about the millennials okay struggling
the organ organization's director uh
general tedros ottoman
you will just call him ted
says they'll make the announcement asap
that stands for as soon as possible cat
but what a relief to the victims i may
be covered with ulcers and sores but at
least i'm not being stigmatized what but
of course this is the same woke health
organization that had a problem with
wuhan virus and we saw how that whole
thing turned out
my bat fillet stand at the wet market
never recovered
it's true sounds delicious and really if
they're worried about animal names what
about their hippocratic oath
i know i know it's disgusting we go now
to the doctor in charge of changing the
name
doctor can we call it the chimp pox
doctor can we call it gorilla fluenza
[Laughter]
yes doctor everyone is wondering when
can we go back to having sex with
monkeys
[Applause]
tyrese i've been trying to come up with
names do you have any any new names no
but i do have just a slight observation
so the big thing was the stigmatism that
someone like think of it as racist but
they made a racist or a a horrible
stereotype in their thing saying that
only monkeys come from africa
ever been to south america
they've been down there they've got a
ton of monkeys down
so
you're going to get rid of
the name
so you're going to get rid of smallpox
of course right is that very offensive
oh no
that's true
there is there is no large pox is there
no we're healthy
top of the food chain like if we were
puppies we eat you just
pee on yourself over there and
judge jeanine adopts you and nurses you
back to health
i could ride in my escalade with my dogs
you're the one that she's gotta hold and
put in a little purse cause your little
legs can't keep up with the other ones
it's created a whole narrative about my
life so you know change that spirit yeah
i hate for someone to do that to me
speaking of chickenpox
yeah
well the thing about
nobody's asking them to change the name
of chickenpox because like kevin spacey
got offended because it was the kind of
boys he likes i mean you know nobody
asked no nobody asked that
yes exactly there you go i'm very
interested as to was there some sort of
like monkey rights organization that
that you know made this sort of push for
this and exactly these are the same
people that kind of the world health
organizations and all these left-wing
people the same people that give you
tampons and men's bathrooms okay so we
need to stop listening to all of them
you know um judge uh this monkey pox is
spread by anal sex at raves care to
comment
no
and no it's caused by humans having sex
with monkeys no it's well no but it's
friends i just read it spread by
anonymous
yourself to the monkey
what did you say no one introduces
himself to the monkey
good evening i'm tyrus thank you for
coming yeah you're my kind of guy look
that way
here's the thing
the monkeys are not suing who cares i
know
but you know what i believe
and one last thing that monkey's from
asia oh really yeah that's the macaque
that's from india tyra says something
about monkeys having sex against their
will are we back to the hunter buying
laptop again
you did it
you did it
all right cats uh let's get some mature
analysis
catherine c timf is here yeah yes
yes um can you tie this into the
monetary fund oh absolutely listen i i
sometimes i have trouble because i'm up
all night reading about the monetary
fund and i don't get enough sleep uh no
i could be a scientist i realized why
because i didn't want to be
because i didn't really like to do
science right but now they don't do
science
they just say stuff yeah
i got a lot of experience doing that
yeah you do you do the priorities the
priorities now are words over treatment
i could go in there and help them name
the pox i can go up there and just say
stuff about stuff i already been doing
that for years
how could i not be the next fouchy i
don't know have you come up have you
come up with any work any i like oh so
it's it's sex you get it outdoor
festivals like
bummer pox what bummer pox because it's
a bummer and butt got it boom wow i was
going to go with festive ulcers that's
well that's oh
no that could be many
festive ulcers yeah festive ulcers oh
all right enough of this uh wholesome
crap hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else